scp-096 versus scp-835  the terrifying unstoppable killer known  as the shy guy against a truly sickening  abomination which would win let's find  out 835 is a huge underwater monster  made from human flesh a kind of  nightmarish coral formation with giant  grasping tentacles it drags people  inside to add to its own biomass and  releases an infectious pathogen that  transforms humans into terrible violent  beasts however we still think  scp-096 would have a good chance to  survive here not only is it hardy and  relentless it also isn't human and  scp-835 appears specifically geared to  integrate humans into its body as a  result there's a good chance that 096  would be immune to the worst of  scp-835's effects and that might be  enough for it to fight back and take  home the win